this video is brought to you by keeps
what's up wisecrack jared here and today
we're going to talk about clowns and the
IP that made them the stuff of
nightmares
crusty I have to warn you people's
attitudes have changed about yeah except
it wasn't the Simpsons that did this to
our collective cultural subconscious it
was Stephen King's in now originally
published as a novel in 1986 and then
later adapted to a two-part miniseries
in 1990 it received a facelift recently
in the form of two blockbuster films the
first film got rave reviews racking up a
solid 85% on Rotten Tomatoes and
smashing it at the box office
did chapter 2 repeat the success well
let Stephen King answer that yeah I
didn't like the ending yeah it was
disorienting ly bad so what happened
wisecrack how could chapter 1 hit it out
of the park while chapter 2 struck out
swinging while we could point to a lot
of things we think the central problem
has to do with the way that horror films
are structured welcome to this wisecrack
edition on it chapter 2 what went wrong
and spoilers ahead for chapters 1 & 2 oh
and the book as well but before we get
into it I want to give a shout out to
this week's sponsor keeps you may have
noticed that I haven't gotten a chance
to get a haircut in the past couple
months at the end of the day I can live
without a visit to the barber it's not
that bad of a problem however if I were
losing my hair I know I would do
everything in my power to prevent it
prevention is the key to keeping your
hair and avoiding hats isn't enough
keeps is an affordable hair loss
treatment program that helps you keep
your hair with FDA approved
over-the-counter and prescription
medication keeps can tailor a prevention
plan to your specific needs you meet
with a doctor right from the comfort of
your own home and the medication will be
shipped to your front door
find out why keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
why nearly 100,000 men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication by
clicking the link in the description or
by going to keeps calm / wisecrack if
you use our link you can get 50% off
your first order so stop stressing and
keep your hair and now back to the show
all right let's dive into a quick recap
of the
films it chapter one follows a plucky
gang of self-described losers as they
navigate the challenges of growing up in
small-town America they get bullied fall
in love and oh yeah
get tormented by this guy as it turns
out the town of Derry isn't quite like
other towns kids are going missing
including Georgie the younger brother of
our lead loser bill the cause one very
hungry clown named penny wise bill tries
to convince his friends to face this
cackling menace in order to save his
brother but the group disbands after a
seriously messed up encounter at penny
wisest crack house of horrors next time
will be better prepared no you're insane
that is until Beverly gets kidnapped
which forces the team back together they
then descend into the sewers overcome
their fears save Beverly and defeat
penny wise well for now chapter two
picks up 27 years later when penny wise
has come back and the gang has to
reunite in order to beat penny wise for
good the group has to collect items that
were important to them from childhood
and sacrifice them in some suitably
vague Native American ritual after the
team collects their tokens they meet up
to defeat penny wise except that ritual
yeah didn't work good that's good
instead the team is forced to confront
their childhood traumas again until they
overcome them and arrive at the
convenient realization that penny wise
as a projection of their fear will
shape-shift into whatever they think of
him as as he dribbles into a baby clown
thing the group rips out his heart and
crushes it thus freeing the town of
Derry from the torments of it now on
paper these films seem pretty similar
the group gets together overcomes their
fears and takes down a demonic clown so
why does this formula work in the first
film but not the second well we think it
has to do with the way structure and
timing work both in horror and in movies
at large as the master of girls Alfred
Hitchcock said there is no terror in the
bang only in the anticipation of it and
it's precisely this understanding of
timing or lack thereof that makes
chapter one so good and Chapter two so
bad so let's dive in
to screenwriting guru John York a
properly constructed scene should
structurally mirror your archetypal
three-act film structure to York
storytelling is ultimately fractal in
nature kind of like a pattern that
repeats itself regardless of the scale
in his book into the woods
he writes stories as a whole illustrate
complete change acts show major change
and scenes of minor individual moments
it's in the latter these single cells of
the organism that a writer's effort is
concentrated for each is a unit of
change and just as a movie is usually
told in three acts so can a scene
usually be divided into three main parts
first our protagonist wants to do
something only to be thwarted by another
character or force of antagonism before
a choice is made and one of those two
opposing forces gives way now it's
important to note that this tripartite
structure isn't a hard and fast rule
frankly there are as many ways to
formulate a scene as there are fast and
furious movies that being said we found
that a good scare can usually be broken
down in this way while a bad one usually
rejects it to see this in action though
we need to examine some key scenes from
both movies perhaps the most iconic
scene of both films is the opening scare
for chapter 1 in this iconic moment we
see the three-part structure pretty
clearly first let's start with the
action Georgie wants his boat back to
that end he answers penny wisest
seemingly harmless questions about his
life and his friends where is he
throughout this exchange we aren't
scared per se but it's easy to say that
tension is building of course
Georgie is rightly skeptical that is
until Pennywise insists they're not
strangers anyway meet Georgie Georgie
meet penny wise this launches us into
the second phase reaction anywise
insists on building a rapport and the
two of them start actually getting on
much to our increased heart rate and
dread they talk about the circus and
popcorn
that is until penny wise gets hungry
this is the halfway point of our
reaction phase where momentum shifts and
our stomachs really drop to the floor we
then have to watch as penny wise
convinces Georgie to reach into the
drain for his boat
Georgie is going to have to make a
choice and that's
the first real scare happens yeah to say
the least
it's effective and propels us to our
third and final component turning-point
the momentum has shifted
Pennywise has come out on top as a
one-armed Georgie whales and tries to
escape the music crescendos and we are
left with one terrifying image almost
every successful scare in Chapter one
follows this three-part structure
consider the scene in which Eddy strolls
past the well house naturally Eddy wants
to get the F out of there while the well
house well the house has its own ideas
so Eddy tries to leave and this is our
action beat but he ends up fumbling his
pill bottle while scrambling to pick up
his medicine though he's greeted by the
force of antagonism in this case a lever
this is our reaction beat and it sends
Eddy running the only problem is that
he's now running in the backyard of the
well house and oh yeah there's a
chain-link fence back there this is our
turning point where our protagonists and
antagonists are pitted against each
other and that antagonists
well that's penny wise now that's scary
this payoff is all the more satisfying
and scary precisely because it was
preceded by mounting moments of terror
of course just when it seems Eddy's
about to go the way of young Georgie he
finds a hole in the gate and escapes
though undoubtedly scarred for life
but while chapter one is clearly
competent at structuring scares chapter
two is quite a bit Messier let's
breakdown the scene when grown-up Ricci
returns to his childhood arcade to
collect his token while there he has a
flashback in which he recalls playing
video games with another kid only to
have that kid call him out in front of
Bowers as gay why are you being weird
I'm not a boyfriend
then Bowers shouts Ritchie out of the
arcade leaving him to wander the park oh
right and Ritchie then gets chased by a
demonic lumberjack statue if you're
wondering why this part wasn't
particularly terrifying it's not because
the brawny towel dude isn't a little
frightening
it's because the film doesn't build into
the scare none of the action in the
arcade Prime's us for the scare so when
our lumberjack comes out swinging it
seems pretty much out of nowhere but
it's not like this lack of an effective
three-part structure is
isolated event in Chapter two whether
it's Bill reliving his trauma or Eddie
going for round two with the leper each
scene reaches a scare in the
turning-point stage that has nothing to
do with the antagonist in the action or
reaction stages for example let's look
at when Ben reminisce is about hiding
out in a classroom with Beverley - a
small false scare here the conflict the
scene revolves around been wanting to
tell Beverley his true feelings we have
the action in which Ben is worried about
how they'll get on then the reaction
which Beverley says it should be firing
as long as the two of them can still
hang out then decision time is the
turning point as Ben decides to lean in
for the kiss and gets rejected and
that's where the film attempts to get
scary out of nowhere Beverley decides to
go all Ghost Rider which leads to been
sharing a locker with penny wise
confusing yes scary no sure there might
be a three-beat structure to this scene
but these beats don't build to the final
scare largely because beats 1 & 2 feel
like they were ripped from a teenage
romance novel instead of these beats
focusing on a potential scare they're
focused on the will they won't they
aspect of Beverly and Ben's relationship
of course there are other places in
chapter 2 where the film seems to get
this right only to later throw it out
the window take the scene where Beverly
revisits her child at home after Beverly
low-key vandalizes her old bedroom to
find her token she sits down for tea
with the apartments new owner one sweaty
older woman in pursuit of a sinister
seeming but unspecified end but you know
what they say about Gary no one who dies
here ever really dies the conversation
starts pleasantly but quickly becomes
uncomfortable when the woman brings up
death and starts Fanning her corpse like
chest this is the action phase Beverly
sensing something is wrong then tries to
excuse herself the reaction phase here
dread is building as we see penny wise
in a photo and the old woman shimmying
naked in the backdrop one has to give
Beverley or our naked septuagenarian
unsurprisingly it's Beverly the old
woman comes out screaming like Baba Yaga
and Beverly is on the run now yes all of
this fits York's formulation of
action-reaction turning point the only
problem though is that this correctly
structured scare was buried any more
confusing series of scenes it was
preceded by a tense flashback of Beverly
and her abusive father and was followed
up immediately by a strained
conversation with Pennywise taken
together this scare was lost in the mix
of different conflicts and rising
tensions so I think it's fair to say
that the scene structure of chapter 1 is
one of the film's strengths while
structure in chapter 2 is one of its
weaknesses but now let's go back to
York's concept of fractal storytelling
that is this three-part structure
repeats itself not just in scenes but
also the film as a whole now of course
both films do have a three-act structure
but what makes chapter one so good and
chapter two so bad is the spacing of
these scares within their respective
acts just as every fright needs an
earlier setup in the scene so too does
every scary scene need a setup in the
act too many frightening scenes in a row
when you run into a problem of
diminishing returns on the other hand if
there's too long of a drought between
your stairs you start to lose the
tension in the script unsurprisingly
chapter 1 suffers from neither of these
problems while chapter 2 suffers from
both of them to prove this point let's
compare the first act of chapter 1 to
the first act of chapter 2 in Chapter 1
the first act runs from the beginning
right up until the gang realizes they've
all been terrorized by the same clown
meanwhile in chapter 2 act 1 spans from
the opening until bev tells everyone
they're doomed to die and Mike proposes
his stupid ritual the ritual of Troodon
so how many scares were contained in
each films first act in chapter 1 the
answer is a healthy eight scares or
roughly a scare every eight or so
minutes in Chapter two there are four
scares or scare every 15 minutes and
some of these scenes well it's hard to
say if they were actually frights
I mean honestly is penny wise showing up
to eat a drowning man really a horror
scene or is he just appended to a
cliched scene of violence small-town
homophobia even worse only one of these
scares actually happens to our main cast
of characters when monsters emerge from
their fortune cookies and if you're
wondering no there's no action reaction
build up to it instead of building to
periodic scares the first act of chapter
2 is unusually obsessed with comedic
gags
what and exploring the interpersonal
relationships between its characters
this wouldn't be so bad except that it
has the weird effect of further diluting
what little tension there is in the
first act this general lack of rights in
the first act of chapter two however
only creates bigger structural problems
in its second act typically act one is
used to establish our characters along
with their flaws and motivations in
Chapter one we learned that Bill is
obsessed with finding his missing
brother the parents it's the only place
that that that Georgia could vet his
condo while we get to know about the
rest of our ensemble cast through their
run-ins with penny wise Eddie is haunted
by a leper and his fear of germs Mike is
haunted by the fire that killed his
parents and Beverly is haunted by her
father and her nascent sexuality by
combining character introductions with
terrifying moments chapter one manages
to keep audience is engaged in its first
act and masterfully sets up act 2 where
our characters have to face the forces
of antagonism head-on unfortunately for
chapter 2 though the film didn't give us
these introductory run-ins with penny
wise until act 2 that means instead of
watching our heroes fight back in the
second act like they did in the well
house in Chapter 1 we have to re-watch
their character introductions worse
because chapter 2 has to cram these
moments all into its second act the
horror feels formulaic and repetitive
because let's be real jump scares aren't
great when we watch them back to back to
back with acts 1 & 2 lagging in terms of
plot development it's no surprise then
that the third act of it chapter 2 also
falls flat as Billy Wilder the iconic
screenwriter from the Golden Age of
Hollywood said if you have a problem
with the third act
the real problem is in the first act
because chapter 2 didn't give our heroes
a proper introduction and goal in the
first act and has to place a massive
catch up in the second act as a result
when we arrive at the third act when our
characters have to make the choice to
stare down our antagonist we're left
feeling like not much has happened the
team goes back to Derry each one
collects their own token and then they
all meet at the well house for the final
battle let's kill this [ __ ] clown but
without the buildup in the prior acts
this turning point feels anticlimactic
our group hasn't had to overcome any
real
opposition so their decision the face
Pennywise doesn't bear the same weight
worse because the ritual doesn't even
work in the first place
we're wondering why they didn't just
face-off earlier and save us an hour of
time and that face off yeah we already
watched the group beat the lights out of
the clown in the first film now you're
the one who's afraid
ultimately it chapter two is rife with
poorly structured scenes that when
combined make for poorly structured acts
that when combined make for very
disappointed moviegoers but let us know
what you guys think in the comments
below
big thanks to our patrons for supporting
the channel and our podcasts don't
forget to subscribe and as always thanks
for watching guys peace
[Music]